شبه جزيره القرم في المعنى استراتيجي
العسكري تحولت الى نقطه ساخنه للمره
الاولى ربما منذ ضمها لاراضي روسيا عام
خلال 24 ساعه هجمتها القوات الاوكرانيه
باكثر من 70 طائره مسيره الضربه الاكبر
تمت فجر الجمعه بحسب وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
باكثر من اربعين طائره سبقها هجوم باكثر
من 30 مسيره اخرى اسقطت القوات الروسيه
معظمها بالتشويش الالكتروني خبراء يقراون
كثافه الهجمات الاوكرانيه على القرم تبدلا
في تكتيكات الهجوم المضاد تكتيكات تعتمد
على تكثيف الهجمات كما ونوعا كما حدث مع
ما اعلنته كييف من تنفيذ وحدات تابعه لها
انزالا وصفته بالناجح على شبه الجزيره
ما اكدت روسيا انها احبطت الهجوم وقتلت
جميع افراد القوات المهاجمه التطور
الميداني هذا يضاف اليه ضربه غير معتاده
على منطقه كالوجا
الاستهداف تم بصاروخ من طراز 200 معدل
بحسب مقاله موسكو يمكن للصاروخ المعدل ان
يطير لمسافه تصل الى 400 كيلومتر هذا يعني
انه انطلق على الارجح من مناطق في شمال
شرقي كييف خطوره الاستهداف ليس ان كالوجا
قريبه من موسكو بل لانها مركز لابرز
الصناعات الثقيله المدنيه الروسيه فهي
تعتبر مقرا لصناعه وتجميع السيارات
والعربات والسكك الحديديه
القراءه هذه قد تقود الاستنتاج ان
اوكرانيا تتجه الى تكثيف نوعيه هجماتها في
العمق الروسي فان لم تصب هذه الضربات
اهدافها فقد يكون كافيا في هذه المرحله
باوكرانيا ان تربك الداخل الروسي
[موسيقى]